how do everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - all right I can
growl on the walls - you scared of me ah
you were really there
ribbit floaty what was that
kill it Kalen
what is what what what did with their
major what well.alright done maybe the
mostest want a gun ever or I'm not using
your heart no I'm just gonna unload on
this suck-up girl fire Oh draw some
blood
yeah that sucks
nope ah get some wow I can't even cut
limbs off with this thing
where'd you go
no no no no oh no no no really my
goodness
is this thing ever wimpy gonna kill up
baby
maybe I'm just a bad shot with it but
uh-huh I'm aiming for the tentacles okay
one knocked off and then I'm on the room
I remember from Dead Space 1 there is a
power node over this way ah no no ribbon
and a Boojum fuse I said and then nope
if I wanted a machine gun I would have
gone back to the fault record this is
going to make you cough up your babies
Nantz Babu's and thence Baboosh and Oh
fine fine
whatever that is the whoa
hello Wow look at that that's physics
for you that totally makes sense
yes par note and that is still that Wow
ah
on they're giving me rivet ammo my
goodness
whoa cleaned your clock those a black
puker gasps it's a Boomer except they
don't explode anyway I am sincerely
disappointed with both the gun and the
person who suggested the gun I'll stick
with my detonator more maybe you don't
even deserve what I heard you haven't
done is the biggest pile of horse hockey
oh where are these things coming from
yes I love seeker shell that's exactly
what I want for my birthday
morveau huh piercing there a lot of
these guys every nope not on that yep
yeah
Alma by a dance
ah hi come here
I'll talk with you alright you go
where'd you get a giggity go
nope don't worry that's right
open back up door everything opens from
markiplier oh it's back here oh the big
thing all I got a power of this thing
back on for the big rotary doodads huapi
womp womp I love my zero-gravity walk
good on my way I got places to be
Oh Cyril gravity what am i doing swoosh
okay what's this Oh
all DMR good for that okay that's all I
have to do the Beast is back where's the
last one
was that it there we go okay and this
goes right there
that's it what were these pieces doing
out of there anyway
why were they just floating around in
space was that all of them nope missing
one more god damn it
you're stirring it Oh with that no
schematic force energy like I need that
pile of donkeys rule I guess I'd be more
of a fool
it's liquid spill everywhere I'm
pondering drunk donkey drew away too
much all right
where is it I've been flown oh right
there
good yeah
all right that did something what I
don't know very intricate piece of
highly advanced technology a
two-year-old that knows how to play
Legos could do it fit the square peg in
the square hole on land
now what
that looks intense I suppose it is a
gravity centrifuge that is capable of
lifting billions of tons of rock and
also smashing me to bits which I got
smashed I don't think that piece of tarp
is going to hold back the organic growth
okay what am I supposed to do now go
that way
why was that it does it was that while I
needed to do
oh I'm done okay I didn't realize I was
done
yeah I'm so great I finished stuff
before I even know I think stuff yeah
I'll feed again like it ain't no Fang
where was that guy that one guys haha
not again
Oh stare for the yellow what okay
Isaac's going crazy now that's a tough
thing just hallucinate
I'll admit that right why boom I miss ah
what the hell Trustin not obese
understands
oh I heard oh I could a boo-boo better
injecting myself with mystery met each L
le huge online yeah baby if you know
what I mean yeah I know like Stross
wasn't dude Billy wasn't doing - yeah ah
come on
ah bring it [ __ ] I got rivets these
will do me some good
come on oh not little ones ah happen to
your face buddy kind of ugly little boy
ah yeah
come
which is where the gun will be good for
something oh hello kid ordinarily I'm
good with kids
ah oh come on come on ah
come on I don't have it I hate these
little swarming bastards I don't have
time to grab up there good oh you're not
a swarming bastard ha ha ha oh oh stop
puking in my face bro Oh
ah and I just looked over it skyping I
saw that my buddy said don't [ __ ] up
always make sure my weapons are reloaded
frickle frackle everything reloaded god
oh ok that wasted time and energy
okay the first one's gonna hop through
here and then they pop out over there I
don't need to work oh yeah whatever guy
fight what ever I don't even care
anymore
let's see
no get out of here come leaner cool nerd
that's so weak man was this sanitary one
okay that's not as cool hello how you
doing
get ready to die what ah you didn't give
up you're not gonna come back
suck on this
oh geez geez Louise nope nope bro
shots I'm a such a pro I'll give you the
bodies I want the goodies okay switch
old switcheroo
of your arm given that and they're
pretty huge yeah
come or for good measure nope not today
and then I'm gonna kill you your own
hooah
ah what that where did you come from my
gun whoosh my god
whoosh whoosh yeah yeah bro so slow why
my slow prep yeah I didn't die before he
didn't see a damn thing
Isaac stress is starting to worry me
some Lissa worried me for a long time
now but son daddy's not a murderer Oz
he's not real
yes he do it you can't see him because
you haven't taken this step strong I'll
be put down to screwdrive step 3 oh that
not today oops how about it
how about this hahahaha Creek yeah the
way letter e Kenny I wasted two shots
because of a ladder I will murder
someone I will rip out their eyeballs
who's it gonna be
ow my neck there goes my tough-guy
demeanor Oh II bet this crick in my neck
for a while not that I mean to bore you
with my concerns all I'm here for is to
entertain you guys with video games and
my failures or success I don't know it's
a my gun dmg 78 okay in what sort of
engineering aspect could align gun be
used anyway
I mean it's called a line gun but the
only actually military weapon that I
think exists in this game is the pulse
rifles like that's legitimately the only
weapon that has any military aspect
which is concerning cuz he you know you
would think that would be more anyway
screw the rivet gun I mean my gosh
give me back actually let's try
something else you know cuz why not do I
have any other weapon in storage the
flamethrower why not bring it back good
for those little guys I'm sure it will
come in handy for some application okay
I got line racks an Evo plasma energy
pistol ammo
detonators what I meant
okay I need what did I need I need
health packs actually well I still got
the store discounted - bended on so much
essentials okay I need flamethrower few
ah heard our yeah don't mess with me
okay there we go oh that's actually
pretty cheap surprise and sacks up to
150 not bad okay so I could have filled
a lot more than I thought okay
that'll do and that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you guys so much
for watching as always I appreciate
every single one of you and I will see
you you in the next part bye bye